they won't cover anything you know
there's a little story
probably the only place you would have
heard about it is on donald trump's
twitter feed
during the dnc during the convention
during two caucus meetings they said the
pledge of allegiance well good for them
i'm shocked they even did that
but these leaders of the caucus meetings
left out the phrase
under god pledge of allegiance very i
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america to the republic
for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all we used to learn that as
school children probably they don't
learn that now
the democrats because they're still
catering to an older generation they say
it
but they take out under god now i've
been told reliably by usa today
fact check dnc did not omit under god
from the pledge of allegiance
snope says this is mostly false all the
other mainstream media misleading not
true false take a listen to the opening
of the muslim caucus of the democratic
national convention
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation indivisible
with liberty and justice for all take a
listen to the opening of the lgbt caucus
of the democratic national convention
hello everybody if you don't have a flag
i have flags here
right in front of me please place your
hand over your heart
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation indivisible
with liberty and justice for all
we have them on video we have
the audio we have the receipts and this
lying dishonest mainstream media
are going to look us right in the face
and say no
you didn't hear that no you didn't hear
that that didn't happen
who are you going to believe us or your
lying ears
that is the dear i think even
conservatives don't appreciate
how thoroughly dishonest the press is
it's not just that
george stephanopoulos works for bill
clinton for many years and then he
becomes
a fake journalist and oh he's obviously
got a bias
it's that this entire apparatus exists
to not not only to lie to you
not only it exists to help
the liberal establishment and so if it
if it helps the liberal establishment to
tell the truth they'll do it
but if it helps the liberal
establishment to obscure the truth
they'll do it and if it helps the
liberal establishment to
outright lie even when we've got the
audio they will do that
it's pure cynicism and self-government
cannot operate that way
self-government requires an
understanding of objective truth
self-government requires that we be able
to communicate with one another
self-government requires a legitimate
choice
and we are being denied that choice by
that liberal establishment and what do
they do you know the left always
projects
so they always say trump's a fascist
trump's an authoritarian trump is the
most democratic candidate that we have
had
in this government maybe in a hundred
years certainly
in 30 years but i don't know maybe in a
hundred years
you're getting a legitimate choice here
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you